welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and zack snyder's army of the dead
brings the director full circle to his
dawn of the dead days with an ocean's
eleven style heist or for
fearers of large crowds a typical day in
vegas this movie was filled with homages
to classic
cinema and snyder's past work along with
cryptic clues to
how this fictional history unfolded so
i'm gonna break down all the cool
details you missed in this movie spoiler
warning we haven't seen it yet here we
go
we opened on a military convoy leaving
area 51 and
right away in the sky in the background
two lights are floating up there then
suddenly
zip away as the trucks leave these ufos
might just be a fun nod to this being
area 51
or a possible clue to the origin of the
zombies in this universe because
throughout the film with some of the
zombies
you can see this blue glow emitting from
them which zack snyder actually
explained this saying quote there's a
number of zombies that are clearly not
zombies
you see normal zombies and then you see
some robot zombies
are they monitors that the government
has placed among the zombies to monitor
them
are they technology from the other world
what's happening there
well snyder plans to explore this origin
more in the prequel titles like the
animated series army of the dead las
vegas
or maybe even the live-action army of
thieves which will feature the locksmith
theater
i'm thinking the government recovered
some extraterrestrial bioweapon from a
ufo and then tested it on soldiers
hoping to make them stronger harder to
kill but then
turn them into the alpha zombies better
fit to survive
the next step of evolution to replace
humanity by destabilizing most of
society into these shambler drones that
just kill each other i don't know it's
all just coming from a very grim
imagination for ways the world could and
probably will end some horny newlyweds
caused the convoy to crash
releasing the alpha zombie yours dog tag
suggesting he might have been a soldier
tested on you know when i'm trying to
find the answers to these things
sometimes i just feel like i'm fumbling
through the dark and i just
need a good theory or an easter egg to
cling to as my lifeline
experience that is a lot like the
sponsor of this video state of survival
so state of survival is a free to play
zombie themed survival strategy mobile
game available in both apple and google
app stores
you just click the link in this video's
description to download it now big news
in the world of zombie mobile games
folks from now until october
you can play as daryl dixon and other
characters from amc's the walking dead
this is basically like batman showing up
in an x-men movie
it's a big deal it changes the game in
state of survival you can join an
alliance or play solo to grow your
settlement and recruit heroes to fight
zombies and other real players around
the world
as part of the walking dead crossover
they're also featuring daily trivia quiz
events with real prizes
and collectible walking dead easter eggs
hidden throughout the game it's
basically like that catnip for new
rockstars fans you know the story is
great it's full of twists and turns
there's a giant corporate conspiracy
lots of zombies to kill this game is a
blast so
download state of survival now using the
link below and use my creator code new
rockstars sos to redeem as an
in-game starter pack the number of
starter packs are limited so act now and
then we get this direct homage to the
horror classic american werewolf
in london
holy [ __ ] are you kidding me it really
scared me
you really scared me you [ __ ] you
couldn't help me up or what
now this convoy's codename was four
horsemen uh less than subtle nod to
their role as harbingers of the world's
inevitable apocalypse but also a sort of
callback to snyder's opening montage in
the 2004 dawn of the dead which featured
johnny cash's when the man comes around
and ends with cash quoting the four
horsemen passage from the book of
revelation
a pale horse and his name that set on
him was death
and hell followed with him and then in
this movie snyder includes a similar
world falling apart opening montage
you're set to viva las vegas and
starting with a liberace impersonator
playing
unaware of the chaos behind him and we
see a zombified bachelorette party with
chip and dale's dancers
and one of the women sasha's reads bad
influence
which she very much is keep away from
this one zack snyder said he himself
cameos in this movie just very briefly
for two frames or so
reflected in a mirror sitting behind the
camera the editors were gonna take it
out but he said he would leave it in but
yeah you can see him here now marching
through this madness is our
zombie zero the alpha zombie named zeus
in this movie he's played by richard
cetrone
a long time stunt performer and fight
coordinator who's worked with snyder on
a ton of stuff
justice league watchmen 300 and then
later on this zombie grows hair
showing how he's not really dead exactly
but kind of a new evolved life form
and yeah with the name zeus and his home
base being olympus
named after the home of the gods mount
olympus in greek mythology
casting zeus and all these other alphas
as kind of gods these lesser mortals
have to fight and in the wide shot of
this walled off las vegas strip we get
this great shot of the full
sea of zombies and they're swarming
around this flaming bus
which does kind of evoke snyder's
visuals in dawn of the dead when the
survivors escaped the mall threw a thick
crowd on an armored bus
dave bautista plays scott ward a former
military helped a lot of people escape
las vegas but now just works a grill at
the
lucky boy diner until bly tanaka shows
up offering him a 50 million dollar cut
of the 200 million dollars in the vault
of his vegas casino before the city gets
nuked tanaka is played by hiroyuki
sonata whom we just saw as hanzo
hisashi's scorpion in mortal kombat and
like
a ton of other great stuff and tanaka
sends along with them the head of
security martin for the real prize a
severed alpha head so that they can make
an
army of alphas for sale so they can
profit in the billions of this
you get a quick camho from political
figures donna brazile and sean spicer
debating the quarantine camps and the
ethics of nuking the city which the
president of this world plans to do on
july 4th because it would be
quote pretty cool and kind of patriotic
so ward takes the job and he puts the
team together including maria and
vanderhoe an interesting character he's
got this omega tattoo on his chest
which when the trailer came out a lot of
fans jumped on as a possible dark side
easter egg for the snyder cut but really
omari hardwick already has this tattoo
snyder told him that they wouldn't have
to cover up the tattoos because the
characters form are military
and that omega symbol does still work
for the character
foreshadowing van der hoe's role as the
final alpha
the alpha and the omega the new god as
he carries the zombie's legacy to mexico
city
a new beginning in the final scene also
notice this shot of vanderhoe is him
caring for this woman in the pool
in a baptismal pose paralleling the
imagery of the other alpha
zeus going through his own baptismal
ritual at that zombie pool in olympus
comedian tignerturo plays helicopter
pilot peters she's actually cast in this
world to replace chris delia late in
production
so you may notice a lot of her scenes
are shot with quick cut into her and
just completely different framing
or her body vfx into wide group shots
you can definitely notice it when they
first enter vegas with their guns drawn
then the locksmith
deer marvels over the vault design i'm
going to mispronounce this it's the
gyatrong
i'm sorry he explains how the name comes
from the wagner opera
the ring of the nibilung again i'm sorry
but the word itself
translates to downfall but also rebirth
it actually stems from the old norse
phrase ragnarok so yeah another parallel
to the end of the world here but not
just the end
the start of a new cycle actually
wagner's music returns later when the
vault opens
this music was also used in the film
excalibur which zack snyder loves it's
one of his biggest influences he
referenced in batman v superman
so as the team plans a mission like in
the movie ocean's eleven this movie
shows us a hypothetical version of this
heist unfolding
and we see this circular team up shot
it's a lot like that shot in avengers
but
dieter steps out of it and by doing so
he kind of reveals how goofy and tropey
that kind of shot is
it almost feels like zack snyder taking
a shot at joss whedon here doesn't it
why wouldn't he be upset with him
and tanaka says at the end of the
mission they'll fly off into the sunset
and we see the helicopter framed in the
sun
just like the iconic poster for our
apocalypse now though i think the story
goes that image was only on the poster
was never actually in the movie maybe
reflected how in this movie
that shot is not in the actual sequence
of events it's just something they
expect might happen
actually snyder directly references
apocalypse now by including a version of
the doors the end as the groups makes
their way into vegas the song that
martin sheen had is fun little dance too
at the beginning of apocalypse now and
then the coyote lily leads them
into the city along with ward's daughter
kate going after her refugee friend gita
and lily tricks cummings into being an
offering to the alphas and i just love
how cummings is at the tail end of this
running joke of the team members being
offered less and less of the cut
with cummings taking a mere 20 000 and
being the first killed off
actually with the exception of maria i
think the team dies in reverse order of
the size of the cut they were getting
now overseeing this toll exchange
is zeus standing atop the statue of
liberty from the new york new york
casino
actually recalling the closing shot of
the wreck statue of liberty and planet
of the apes another apocalyptic story
about an evolutionary overthrow now
during these scenes snyder includes one
shot of zeus's bride with a super
shallow depth of focus
as she backs away further and further
out of focus actually similar camera
work that you might remember snyder
using on jared leto as a joker in that
reshot ending of the snyder cut snyder
actually acknowledged that he used the
same lens for that scene that he used
here in army of the dead since for that
snyder cutscene a real limited
set for that reshoot and they passed a
billboard for larry fong's magic show so
larry fong
is snyder's long-time director of
photography worked with him on batman
superman sucker punch watchman and he
actually
shot the pilot of lost super talented
guy also a super talented magician who
loves to hide the three of clubs in all
of his movies which schneider does for
him here
also larry's a really nice guy who
complimented our breakdown on twitter a
batman v superman last august and then
once they get to bly's casino the group
splits up dieter vanderhoe and gusman go
down to the vault basement where they
find the remains of a past
team that tanaka had sent in before them
with the members weirdly matching them
you see ward's red scarf maria's key
around her neck so vanderhood might be
onto something with his
existential rant about them being stuck
in a time loop maybe not actual time
travel in this film universe i guess
we'll see
but at least they are kind of in a cycle
repeating with vanderhoe
as the new alpha at the end of the movie
and when they finally get that vault
open
to the side of the door you can see a
row of film reel canisters
zack snyder actually put these in there
saying that they were gonna be the reels
of his own snyder cut footage that he
kept in his vault
because when this movie was shot snyder
had yet to assemble the new snyder cut
that was released on hbo max so martin
beheading the bride
leads to her and zeus's unborn fetus
dying you see that blue glow there
fading just another example of how these
alphas are a new species
so he deploys his troops who deliver the
craziest kill of the movie to poor maria
and activates the rage of drax the
[Applause]
destroyer
meanwhile van der rohe fights zeus one
on one alpha versus omega if you think
about it but we never see
when exactly he gets bitten but it
weirdly does take a long time for this
infection to take hold from being in the
vault through the nuclear blast through
his long walk in the desert through
buying that private jet through this
flight to mexico i mean we're talking
several hours so
in the movies final act lily sacrifices
herself on the roof to let them escape
lets that bride head go plop but then
ward and peters go up to olympus to
rescue kate
and gita but they gotta fight zeus on
the helicopter and he eventually shoots
zeus and the head emitting this blue
glow once again
and then over the final scene naturally
we hear cranberry zombie
leading to this epilogue with vanderhoe
emerging from that vault with millions
of cash
hiking exhausted to this house in the
desert now actually this is all shot in
albuquerque new mexico and it reminds me
a lot of walter white hiking through
this same desert with millions in cash
in that great final season episode of
breaking bad osimandius another survivor
on a lonely trek inevitably to death
with
way more cash than he could ever spend
hey subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis and breakdowns of the movies
you love and thanks again to state of
survival for sponsoring this video
download the
game from the link in the description
and use my creator code new rockstars
sos for a free in-game starter pack and
support this channel by checking out one
of our many great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me at eavos
fellow new rockstars thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you